si on y va là bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france
alors les etats-unis peuvent-ils
concrètement empêcher tik tok de
fonctionner sur le sol américain
alors bonjour il les états unis peuvent
techniquement empêcher le téléchargement
ce que prévoit le décret donc à partir
de dimanche
c'est que les applications qui ont déjà
été téléchargées reste bien évidemment
sur les smartphones les ordinateurs des
des consommateurs américains mais en
revanche il ne sera plus possible en
théorie de télécharger de nouvelles
versions de cette de cette application
tik tok et oui chat est notamment de ne
plus ensuite utiliser les mises à jour
qui pourrait être faite ce qui rendrait
obsolète les anciennes versions déjà
déjà existante et il serait donc
interdit aux plateformes donc à apple et
android de utiliser les applications
dans leurs stores dans l'eure dans leur
boutique en ligne
donc techniquement c'est possible alors
en revanche ce qui est prévu c'est que
tik tok va avoir un espèce de délai
jusqu'au 12 novembre vous l'avez vous
l'avez indiqué pour trouver
éventuellement une solution avec avec
oracle pour que ce cette application
soit rachetée aux états unis alors bien
évidemment je précise que tout ça ne
concerne que les états unis les cieux
qui ont quitté tôt qu'en france ne sont
absolument pas impactés par par cette
décision unilatérale des états unis et
d'un point de vue juridique est ce que
les états unis ont un arsenal pour faire
interdire cette application il y à
l'arsenal existe il a déjà été mis en
place et pas plus tard que hier au donc
dans la le tribunal de district de san
francisco un juge a émis l'hypothèse que
heures ça concerne oui chat que le
décret présidentiel de donald trump
puisse être suspendue
peut-être dès aujourd'hui ou dès demain
pour empêcher que la menace ne soit mise
à exécution en revanche tik tok qui a
également fait des recours et a rempli
donc des dossiers de plaintes aux états
unis
demandant en californie pour le moment
la suspension n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour mais il est très très possible
parce que les offres ne sont pas order
donc le décret présidentiel sont trop
vagues s'appuie s'applique sur une une
supposée et atteinte à la sécurité
nationale qui n'est absolument pas
démontré
et il ya bien évidemment le premier
amendement le sacro-saint ce premier
amendement des états unis qui protège la
liberté d'expression qui est bien mise à
mal par sept par ce décret présidentiel
alors justement vous l'évoquez pour les
états unis l'application tik tok n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'un outil
d'espionnage la chine à ce qu'elle peut
effectivement avoir un accès à ces
données des utilisateurs américains
alors oui certainement mais j'allais
dire qu'est ce qui vaut mieux est-ce que
ça soit les chinois qui ont accès à ces
données ou via oracle pl/sql etats-unis
le prince des données personnelles et
leur fuite et nenê n'est pas n'est pas
circonscrit au sol chinois les états
unis le pratiquent également à grande
échelle
il n'y a à priori que que nous européens
qui arrivent on a à peu près endiguer
les lélés phénomène de fuite de données
et de préservation des données
personnelles donc en réalité c'est
seydou le problème c'est l'hôpital qui
se fout de la charité et les états unis
sont sont bien évidemment extrêmement
critiques tels états unis donald trump
par rapport aux chinois mais néanmoins
il faut peut être regarder également du
côté de l'amérique du nord ou qui n'est
pas absolument pas respectueuse des des
transferts de données personnelles et
oracle pas plus que microsoft ne serait
épargné par rapport à ça alors fin juin
landreau 6 1 avait banni les
applications chinoise pour les mêmes les
mêmes trains par les craintes de
sécurité nationale finalement le
protectionnisme numérique qui est en
vogue en ce moment alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle là et c'est une crainte on avait
déjà depuis un certain temps d'une
balkanisation de l'internet c'est-à-dire
que chaque pays pourra sélectionner
fragmenté l'internet en fonction de ses
propres desiderata et ses propres
comptes agences de sécurité et de
liberté d'expression ou autre on le
craignait aujourd'hui on voit que les
tats-unis l'appliquent
et donc c'est une
voilà très très très très inquiétant par
rapport à que chaque pays puisse un peu
à sa guise et de manière totalement
unilatérale parce qu'on voit et que les
états unis même s'il ya des recours
juridiques qu'internet ne puisse être
comme ça fragmenté balkaniser par par un
pays en fonction de ses propres critères
de respect des données personnelles
merci beaucoup tiré valhalla avoir
répondu à nos questions merci pour votre
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste du numérique